net lui 21 juin 9h dans le port de
morlaix alors que certains s'apprêtent à
célébrer la fête de la musique c'est un
drôle de ballet que les badauds amis et
autres journalistes assistent et 8 à
huit de la douche est toujours présente
pour preuve ce pari de deux ans aimant
les yeux avec ses la manche dans sa plus
grande largeur à bord de cette
embarcation quelque peu bizarre mais qui
effectivement ressemble à une deux
chevaux idée folle certes mais les deux
bretons ont fait preuve d'ingéniosité
le moteur développe 65 chevaux pour une
cylindrée de 6 102 centimètres cubes un
poids de 235 kg en ordre de marche la
deux chevaux nautique atteint 23,9 à
faire pâlir les meilleurs catamaran
98 milles nautiques en 6 heures tel est
l objectif mais l'élément est resté
maire après seulement dix milles de
course le moteur a dit jo j'ai plusieurs
fois en raison du clapot à cet instant
le doute s'installe espace
le capot quand on s'arrêtait la première
fois promoteur en ce temps là comme des
gros doutes au sujet ce que ça tiendra
jusqu'au bout n'était pas très très très
loin d'être côtes françaises c'est un
petit peu limite nous
fallait que ça aille jusqu'au bout
nullement découragé passé qu'est didier
relance la mécanique malgré une mer
capricieuse les creux atteignent parfois
de m dans le concert de vagues sur deux
virtuoses sentir bien la moyenne chute à
7 noeuds et contrairement à la logique
plus la vitesse est faible plus la
consommation est importante
les 110 litres embarqués à bord des
vedettes sont très vite consommée
l'idée d'atteindre plymouth s'envole et
à 17 milles des côtes anglaises c'est la
panne sèche demain loto mauvaises
langues le bateau était beaucoup plus
durable et de la consommer beaucoup plus
que plus les 20 heures de traversée
constitue le temps de référence la voie
est tracée mais nous deux bretons ont
juré de relever le défi en seconde
manche